hey do you this is back to the community
days you did that six years
we did it for six years we were canceled
twice but yes we did it for six years
because the people the fans brought it
back in a way
they had is that true or not well yeah
because well when we were canceled the
first time
uh we went to yahoo because yahoo
somehow did some analytics that
that the show was critically acclaimed
and
popular enough for them to try their
streaming service which
they then blamed us on paul feig for
shutting it down which was unfair but i
like to tell people i shut down an
entire streaming service
that seems like something pretty cool
but maybe you do talk about it but i
should just say it
chevy chase yeah yeah i talk about it
all the time you do i
i never heard you talk about but you
know he's someone i loved i grew up with
i was like this is my favorite i used
people you see kind of look like him if
you
if chevy and barbara eden had a baby and
i was like cool
i like him yeah um i met him once he was
cool
uh and then when i heard all this stuff
i kind of got like oh
[ __ ] man was he just a bastard on set
that he just hated
and like there's a lot of thoughts that
go through because you read all the
stuff that people say and you re you
know hear the
the media chatting about it and then my
theory
was that in his world he was like
i'm a movie star i've been a movie star
for a long time and now i'm a guy who
kind of comes up and says a funny line
and does whatever and this isn't good
enough for me
and i don't like being here but that's
just my theory
but i don't know what would happen so
anyway well i think um
there was probably exactly what you just
said uh
i uh he was someone that did not want to
be there for the hours that we were
keeping
and the hours were long there was no
doubt about that and uh and
the hours were the hours because we were
shooting a movie every week it wasn't
it wasn't uh you know documentary style
uh or anything like that except for one
episode
uh and so he didn't like that
and um there was no doubt and i think he
would absolutely agree
he sometimes could be in not great moods
and um and that did so
he would have to be kind of shot out you
know we have to get him
uh you know we have to get him off
out of out for the day because he didn't
want to be there that long
and so that that was a big problem was
that incredibly frustrating as the lead
on the show did you ever have to have a
conversation
did they ask you to talk to him oh i
would tease i would go
i'm literally missing my children
growing up right now
uh but that's fine and um
yeah i mean we would we he was so funny
on the show when you look at what was on
camera
it's super funny it's really good uh
but he was always uh he definitely
did not want to be there those hours and
i think there was some
of the he was a big huge obviously
the biggest comedy star of the 80s
or he was the highest paid at least but
between vacation and fletch and
you know the zillion other movies he did
caddyshack and all that
um it yeah i'm sure there was
some of that but i know he was being
well compensated for it
right that said you get someone like
alec baldwin who did 30 rock who
was in a you know big huge movie star
for a long time and then
you know reinvented himself through that
show
um but you know it was unfortunate then
chevy was you know they left the show
under uh quite crazy circumstances so
um it uh was yeah it was definitely
it it could be tough some days other
days he was great did it sever the
relationship with the other actors is
there anybody who has a relationship
with him who has checked in with him who
still sort of like hey you know you
didn't like being on the show you
retired you're older you whatever it is
or or is it kind of severed i don't know
i still have
i called him a few years ago when i
played him in a movie
uh i was so jealous of that because i
thought i should play him oh
i was so jealous of you i really was
like oh my god joel's so lucky
well i was the right height so yeah i'm
not that tall i'm only six feet thanks
for bringing that up
so yeah um well you're back you would be
much taller but chevy had a bad back
he did have a bad battery yes uh another
reason why i thought i should play him
oh interesting i'm kidding so go ahead
and stay calm down you called him i
called him to tell him that i was gonna
play him you know like there's this
movie
gonna be made and i'm gonna be in and
i'm gonna be playing you
and but he was happy that doug kenny was
getting his
uh finally his due uh which because doug
kenny really is kind of like the
hamilton of
70s comedy as far as you know like with
creating
national lampoon and and then of course
writing
the animal house and and making
caddyshack and then
dying very young uh but uh
uh you know i then i so then i called
him when the movie was made i was like
the movie's coming out now
so uh and what did he answer the phone
he talked to you he was
he did it i mean i would text him to let
him know i was gonna call him uh but
uh he seemed fine with it and you know
but we haven't
spoken i don't know if anybody in the
cast has spoken to him in a few years